c'est donc ça la maire de lille a de
quoi là dedans
on est là
bonsoir ça va les gars ça allait mieux
et ça va me les ont tout petit merci
merci à découvrir que des poumons des os
et ça va sur trois groupes locaux
salut tout le monde je suis pour but
aussi evans est un marathon caritatif en
live sur la plateforme de streaming
twitch organisé par des streamer
français derrière moi c'est là que tout
va se passer c'est dans cette salle que
des gros streamer français vont lever
des fonds tout le week-end pour
l'association humanitaire action contre
la faim est sûre brut on va vous montrer
tout ça en vidéo
jab usd tranquille d'un ton petit set up
ouais ouais là ces moments je vais sur
le bureau pour essayer tous branchés
soit prêt demain jusqu'au poteau matos
la mieux
placée
vous êtes là bas à cause de votre tapis
cruz de con way
par une épidémie
la première fois de l'histoire du z
event l'événement va commencer par un
concert caritatif qui va être lancée par
le youtuber qui fait de la musique pv
nova et la stream aux little big wave
qui va chanter
[Applaudissements]
on est hyper heureux a sonné d'être le
tout premier concert du cired pour la
bonne cause 6
score
m
j'suis
akin ses clients
nasser
[Musique]
non aucune secte
la fin
[Musique]
deux extraordinaires
bah oui quand quelqu'un qu'affrontaient
francophone enfin en concert c'est
j'avais jamais donc sur la grande île
macquarie énormément pv qui est là c'est
grâce à lui que ça se fait parce que
c'est déjà fait tous les arrangements et
où il est trop article est trop facile
j'étais super frustrant partition plein
fondu
[Musique]
d'accord
l'admission
ces bouts de l'armée des lignes c'est
magique c'est pas moi qui dansaient
belgique qui m'achètent
[Applaudissements]
merci pour votre accueil merci de
m'avoir invité ça déchire je reviens
quand vous voulez je fais des gros
bisous action contre la faim dit even
plein de bisous êtes des bons à très
vite merci tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois que j'ai eu c'est
la bombe atomique que même
histoire et histoire est super belle
histoire est super rebelle c'est
magnifique je suis hyper fier je suis
hyper content d'être là l'équipe est
encore
j'y mettais des coups de coudes et tout
jadot s'est montré un peu
[Musique]
le concert est un tout juste de se
terminer il ya quelques streamer qui
sont en train de finir avaient installé
leur set up dans la salle et c'est
demain que le marathon de streaming va
commencer
jma du rt la mer parce qu'à partir du
moment où si tu te lèves tu fais une
activité au pouvoir
alors le goût de figure les plusieurs il
y avait la pression du temps parce que
ajouté un concert c'est quelque chose
qu'on a décidé très tard il y avait
arriver à faire un line-up correcte et
que ça plaise au public parce que le
public c'est toujours la critique la
plus difficile et après moi comme
d'habitude tu te sers mon boulot je
voulais que ça plaise les artistes
jouisseur content d'être là et j'ai
l'impression que ça a été le cas qui se
sont sentis bien accueilli donc pour moi
c'est un contrat rempli très gros en
fait internet vient d'être mis lesquels
elle à 00h36 je veux que ça jouer alors
je vais l'ancien parti immédiatement ces
derniers préparatifs à la je me connecte
à mon gestionnaire de mots de passe donc
tu vas arrêter la caméra petites
racailles c'est la routine a envie de
dire bon on lève 5 millions 10 millions
15 ou ou deux euros c'est la même pour
moi ç'a changé à mon quotidien quoi
c'est la sixième édition du gie event il
faut savoir que tous les ans il arrive à
battre le record de la levée de fonds de
l'année précédente par exemple en 2019
il avait réussi à récolter 3 5 millions
d'euros pour l'institut pasteur
et l'année dernière ils ont levé 5,7
millions d'euros pour amnesty
international
chaque relevé qu'une victoire nous
n'avons pas d'objectif précis mais
disons que là pour le coup j'ai plutôt
confiance en la communauté en fait je
les connais je veux dire à chaque fois
on leur dirait un moment sera plafonnée
à chaque fois nous impressionne chaque
année on se dit ça va pas être battus et
au final on explose le truc donc je
pense qu'on peut faire mieux que l'année
dernière j'y crois en vrai je suis
optimiste on n'est jamais prêt une fois
que s'est lancé c'est parti c'est le
cher
[Musique]
on a essayé de voir plus grand ça se
verra à mon avis dans le dos de la salle
et dans le décor et dans tout ce qu'on a
mis en place et après le reste en
réalité c'est pas tellement qu'il est
géré c'est plutôt chaque streamer
indépendamment j'ai l'impression qu'ils
ont fait des donations gold de ouf qui
se sont donné la mort en amont pour que
ça soit trop bien donc je compte sur eux
mais je suis plutôt confiant
ce soir il faut que je ris ville mais de
nichane gaulle
leçon musique voix elle a en fait je
suis en train de set-up finir le set up
micro et mettre toutes les scènes tu
vois avec ma cagnotte le plein écran le
jeu
allez passer votre
salon
merci à tous d'être là nous faire
confiance nous fait plaisir de vous
accueillir bienvenue à tous les nouveaux
on rappelle le lancement tout le monde
vient derrière adrien c'est lui qui fera
lancement on est tous ensemble le début
et quand il donne le go il vous envoie à
vos posts vous pouvez lancer vos stream
et après chacun est parti ça durera
trois minutes max n'hésitez pas à vous
renseigner si ce n'est pas déjà fait sur
ce que les hôtes ont mis en place
evènement données schengen et cetera le
bus c'est d'interagir ensemble faire des
trucs avec des gens que vous feriez pas
le reste de l'année donc profitez-en la
règle des 25 heures est toujours activé
seulement pas plus de 25 heures
d'affilée pour tout le monde là vous
devez donc cette offre votre image
charity vérifier tout est fait avec des
mots bien
attention 3
[Applaudissements]
je déclare sylvain tous mes papiers
roubaix
tu voulais faire un bon pour le zii
event on vous met un lien en
descriptions